so the best weed is coming from Southern
Oregon to Northern California yeah
you're getting the weed from the
Rednecks exactly exactly and then you
know just through happenstance we ended
up meeting a guy who introduced us to
these Mexicans that were from Sinaloa
which is where the it's it was the
beginning of the weed industry yeah they
made sensimilla they figured out how to
make the bud with that scene Samia you
speak Spanish yeah they were the ones
who [__] figure that all out they're
the best Growers they're Farmers back in
the day back in the you know from the
90s through you know a couple of years
ago they would send members lieutenants
up to Oregon and Northern California to
set up grows to set up these huge
thousands and thousands of plants growth
locally there exactly they just have the
good product to grow they have the
experts they're like the Monsanto yes
yeah and it's all about the seed right
of course and they so and they're the
ones that are willing to go high into
the middle of nowhere in the mountains
and they can rig irrigation to make it
go from whatever water source whatever
river is you know up the way and and
they're able to like make the sunlight
hit the plants through those gigantic
trees and it's like brilliant and then
what you do is and then they find guys
like me and they just dish it off and
they send all the profit back to Mexico
so they heard about you no no no I paid
to meet them oh this is fun yeah bro so
I hit give me this happenstance [__]
that you're talking about there's no
happening you know what the [__] is
going on what what really happened here
so
one of the guys who had introduced us
one of these white boys from Southern
Oregon who actually initially introduced
us to these rednecks they were getting
out of the business the redneck said we
don't want to be in it anymore correct
correct they just made enough money you
know because yeah which never happens
it's very rare right never happens so he
happened to know a guy who a Mexican guy
Mexican-American grew up here and his
uncle was one of the guys growing for
these one of these big scene alone
operations now just so I can get this
right he's growing in America correct
but they're all owned by the sin
allowance all owned by the and these
[__] bro
not only they they don't speak English
they don't know what state they're in
they know they're on the west coast they
don't know where the [__] they are how
do they get in what is it all coyotes of
course yeah okay so they're illegally
yeah are they buying the land or they're
just growing oh they're just they're
just growing in the middle of the forest
they're like squatting on the land and
growing in the middle of a forest now
and eventually they would set up like
greenhouses they got more sophisticated
with it but no dude they were marching
their ass [__] days into the forest
for food like ah no they lug it up okay
they lug it up okay um this is like 2007
2008 exactly they don't do that anymore
because it's not worth it to them like
weed is legal now like they stopped
doing that maybe probably like 10 years
ago they quit sending their guys up here
to do that kind of [__] yeah but it was
wild I was locked up with a dude Mexican
dude from uh Colima just close to
Sinaloa he was telling me that he was
part of he was working on one of these
grow sites he was like in overalls
didn't have shoes on
the place get the spot got raided he ran
into the forest got away and made it
back to Mexico oh wow without shoes off
wow it's like when you drop a dog off in
the park and then he makes it back home
he's gonna find his way home that's
crazy give a horse's head he'll find his
way home yeah wow yeah yeah
okay so they're setting up these things
so you meet this guy yeah well do you
speak Spanish okay so you're able to
communicate with these guys so there's a
little bit more trust maybe actually
it's even less trust I found out do not
go in there speaking Spanish
of course bro of course do not go in
there try to impress these [__]
they're like he spent six months in
Colombia yeah oh I studied in Argentina
you know I'm figuring that if you were
D.A they'd send you down to be one of
these like uh what is it called Narco uh
traffic or whatever guys well no no
you're like an undercover yeah like an
undercover DEA guy but all those dudes
speak perfect Spanish so like and they
were immediately like what the [__] and
and my boy was with me was like no no
he's cool like look at his student ID
yeah yeah yeah yeah you got this at the
quad
he's not a [__] DEA agent okay so how
do you convince them
um
money okay you just go how much you have
to spend to meet them 10 10 Stacks just
say 10 minutes just for the intro but
I'm like I told my partner I'm like dude
it's worth it I think we're on to
something so how'd you hear about them
from the Rednecks no from yes just a guy
I was involved with them and he was he
was a Mexican kid but he grew up in the
states and had this connection one of
his uncles exactly was working in this
grow so I was like just take me down
there I went down there with didn't even
buy anything the first trip right I was
like just let me like what's the ticket
it's official okay two two thousand a
pound
okay I'll be back with 80 grand give me
40 of those things to start and then I
got a guy on the East Coast buying them
for 35 a piece and then you can just do
the math 40 pounds of weed get back down
however long back up now is there any
part as you're about to link up with the
cartel that you're like oh this is where
it gets too big this is a bad idea no
there's no inner self dialogue like oh
cartel is not are you [__] up are you
weirdly thinking it's safer because
you're cutting out more interactions the
more people that know the more chances
you go down it was of course yeah I was
like I I was like yeah this is not only
it's not only safer but once I met the
dude on the East Coast that was like he
was like how much can you get me a pound
for 35 that cheap I called I was like
we're about to get rich it's like we're
about it moment you're buying for two
selling it for like flipping four yeah
yeah and if he was buying in bulk like
like 10 or more I'd give it to him for
three it didn't matter 50 exactly if I'm
making a thousand fifteen hundred profit
per piece and we're doing 40 or 50 of
those a week it's a million dollar spot
so
and and that's and that's what my friend
was like I'm gonna get out I think I'm
gonna walk because he made how much he
made first of all how much are you
making a month on this at the height so
80. she's making 80 grand a month 80
after expenses and yeah I'm averaging
some months were better but I want to be
like I want to like say you're making a
million a year okay exactly so you make
a million a year for how long before he
goes okay I think I'm good no no I
bought him out before any of this
happened wait you bought him out yeah
yeah he wanted out he wanted out and
then he also wanted to be bought out
that's a weird thing to buy someone out
of an illegitimate business it was just
out of respect it was just out of
respect how much did you give him I gave
him 20 grand yeah because that was like
because The Re-Up back then like what
you have in the pot to make your your
re-ups your buys yeah it was about 40 or
50 Grand so like here this is your half
anyways you know and we didn't know we
didn't really know it was gonna hit like
this of course you're like when you
think you're on to something you're like
I think we're gonna get rich but we
didn't really know how did you find the
guy on the East Coast
yeah I was
this is the most white boy way I love
this yes amazing aren't white people the
best dude
how many friends got out
I got out and I didn't miss a beat
okay okay okay yo so I'm I'm sorry rugby
yeah
Andrew it was Polo okay it was respect
respect um no I meant I was studying it
because you know I was failing in school
I was [__] up left and right you know
what I mean STDs all that [__] so yeah
hell yeah dude hell yeah thanks so I was
like oh but but you can get a bunch of
credits by just like studying abroad
it's like a joke right so I was like
okay if I do this I graduate on time so
I studied in Argentina for like three or
four months you went to Spain right yeah
yeah same [__] yeah so I'm kicking it my
best friend down there was a dude from
Philly you know just one of these like
dirty Philly kids right yeah
um just [__] the worst white people
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um and he he all of his friends were
connected they were all like either
their parents were Mobsters yeah uh no
no connected like the garbage business
like like Mafia yeah yeah I thought she
went like okay is that the sign you know
oh okay sure sure
[Laughter]
so so yeah so um but all those dudes are
into drugs now like the mafia has long
since like relinquished like that we
don't sell drugs policy you know what I
mean if that was ever a policy I think
that was romanticized on the goblin I
think so I'm a little part of it I think
there was long ago like people that
recognize like Meyer Lansky was never
like we're gonna sell drugs you know
what I mean gambling women all that [__]
but Palestine
that can affect Too Many Lives
yeah yeah so
um I'm sorry so um we uh yeah so he was
he was like my best friend down there
we're going out getting drunk all this
[__] and it was surreal I was fine
he was finally like okay so so you're
buying everything you're F I have my own
apartment like I didn't even live with a
family down there right you know how
most students like course yeah have to
stay in like a you know a studio
apartment with 10 people I was like I'm
just gonna go get my own high rise on
the river you know yeah right yeah
um and so he was like what the [__] you
know like he game recognized game and I
was like yes what I do blah blah are you
doing it while you were there no no no I
would take a hiatus
gotcha you know so money's always moving
right yeah and he was like oh yeah my
friends you know uh uh what's the school
in Temple or whatever yeah you know all
their parents are [__] mob dudes and
all that [__] and yeah this is what they
do it'd be wild
you know you could get them their weed
you know they'd probably pay oh for the
West Coast it's nice smooth and then see
how like how subtle he's asking you to
do it yeah oh he's the pro that's gonna
pick up on that at all yeah he's a pro
so uh and I was like oh yeah that would
be crazy I think he might be you know
yeah
no so we're like oh yeah that's wild and
then we just didn't even think about it
right we didn't think I'm like oh but
that's crazy like how do you move
product out there I gotta like pay
somebody to drive it out there he's just
gonna steal it like you can't do that
what are we drug traffickers
so
but then like six months later
we graduated
and I'm watching this like
I think it's like a CNN like expose on
how people traffic weed through the mail
oh you thought this was going to deter
me this is a [__] video dude I guess
that's what my show is right yeah yeah
yeah so I was like okay let's see if
there's something here and you know just
little by little we start with like
sending a couple ounces over you know
doing this through USPS or UPS or all
three okay all three so there's the the
USPS Post Office yep there's FedEx and
there's UPS
um
UPS is the worst they're [__]
criminals okay don't call me the
criminal wow those [__] stole
so much packages from me bro yeah they
know they just know yeah and they've got
scumbags working for them and I guess
they don't shake them down when they
leave the Sorting warehouses wherever
they go yeah because we had several
boxes with like 10 or 15 pounds in them
yeah that would show up weeks later to
the address Gone Gone oh there'd be no
weed in it should still deliver it so
they would still figure out a way to
deliver it you know dude I had a
I want to get back to I had a friend of
mine's in this cereal business and uh
they're shipping cereal around the
country right all of a sudden they get a
call from one of their uh from like the
police or something somewhere and they
go hey uh we had to pull over your
trucker Uber does Freight okay we have
to pull over the Uber free and um
because there was drugs in your shipment
and then they go what they go yeah there
was like a lot of drugs you had like a
few pallets of cereal then drugs and
then more pounds of cereal right and
then she's like I don't know what the
[__] is going on this is really weird so
they arrest the guy they find out and
they start looking back into their
shipping logs right and they would find
that the cereal would make it to certain
destinations but only like half of it
and then a week later the other half
would show up and basically what the
shipping company was doing was taking
out using the drugs using that to get
the drugs around yeah squeezing in
between but still making sure all the
shipments got there so you would be
nonetheless oh oops
no it's brilliant it's on Uber yeah
Uber's the one doing the freight wow wow
that's one of the things I recommend in
how to episode 18 how to move drugs
efficiently yeah you [__] you use one
of those like third-party huh
thanks
would have been nice 45 minutes ago
I'm looking over here for the last hour
well you don't have other people lined
up to work here come on be a little
afraid you know
um so yeah that's that's a common method
and then they can't put it on you so if
you own a shipping company yeah it's
like I just got the bill of sale I just
ship what people bring to me yeah so
it's like and that's why actually Chapo
became who he was is because he he
perfected how to distribute no to
smuggle bulk coke through you know on
legal freight trucks across the border
because so that's really what makes
somebody special in the game it's
distribution because that's the most
difficult part anybody can cop somebody
was telling me about that I was talking
to somebody about um Escobar and my
understanding of Escobar was the genius
was his ability to distribute and the
way that he like won over that girl what
was the girl's name she's like the
cocaine cowgirl or whatever
Griselda apparently like she was like I
need this much coke in Miami by tomorrow
or something crazy she walks out the
door leaves that it's like if you do it
you're in and if you don't you're not
and like he just had the ability to make
these things happen yeah it's funny that
distribution because because like Amazon
that's what I was about to say it's like
Amazon
it doesn't matter what it is yeah
they're just way higher Stakes here but
back in the day it was easy Escobar
could literally fly a plane and land it
in Miami now you can't do that anymore
so it's really the game that [__] about
the ogs
which ones
a lot of them we're going to film with
Griselda his uh her son Michael Corleone
next week in Miami get out of here yeah
yeah we're doing all right so uh yeah so
but it was the Mexicans that made uh the
the Colombians work for the Mexicans now
you want to know the truth let's go yeah
yeah let's go right next those are the
best number one the number one there's
thank you bro they're the best Latins
for sure you know yeah
so so but you know it's at the point now
where uh yeah it's like the Colombians
are begging people to give the Mexicans
to take their coat because the Mexicans
got because they can get in North
America of course they own they
monopolize the land border it's like
it's us or nothing plus they have
fentanyl coke uh they're selling weeds
still uh so it's like it's like what can
I what can you do for me so we were down
filming in Sinaloa yeah where it all
jumped off last month with Chapo's son
ovidia we were in culiacan I got this
[__] this rosary actually from a
sicario that was guarding El Mayo who's
the last remaining uh Senor from the old
you know Kingpin era you spoke to him no
no no we can never get that close we
spoke to his bodyguards and they're cool
to talk to you like they they went off
camera they didn't let they didn't let
us film off camera and [__] yeah
way you can and can't get away with
we're kind of learning as we go
in the name of the cartel and I'm like
I'm sure people know they sell drugs
yeah but you just sang I sold for them
probably not the best look are they
upset about that no hearing anything all
they all want to be on camera they all
want to be you know every OG
so so it's on some uh what was the movie
uh with Denzel where he wears the
[__] mink uh American American
Gangster yeah and what was what was
prolific about him was his ability to
stay low profile right and then they
marketed this part of the movie as in
like hey the second you want the
attention it's over that's the whole
goddy thing too so you're saying that
these guys despite having all the riches
and all the Liberties and all the
freedoms they still want it's not enough
they still they still want ego they have
ego they still want attention they want
like man what is man really driven by
money yes but people want respect they
want respect
exactly yeah and anything you do so it's
not enough to live in the shadows it is
for the old guys because they understand
it correct and El Mayo zambaba who's
sicarios we talk to he is he's the last
guy because he there's only three
existing photos of him and yeah and this
is and he's probably connected with the
CIA and the DEA you know he he feeds I
want to get into it feeds the cartel he
feeds the government other cartel
leaders this is what you don't know
about it's a dirty little secret
tell bosses every now and then just like
when Frank Lucas wore the mink and he
got a little too hot yeah every now and
then somebody from the Mexican and
United States government yeah yeah we'll
see a guy and he's getting too big he's
gotta let him eat exactly we got to feed
you something I gotta let you eat and
zambata has been feeding he fed them
choppo he fed them uh probably ovivio
Chapo's son who they just went and
snatched uh that they're all and
shopping you stay alive exactly and they
don't look at it as ratting though they
don't look at it as snitches
it's business it's part of
how you do business part of how you
survive they don't look at it because
they're at the highest levels where
they're already interacting with the
police they're already interacting the
police know all of it yeah so it's like
the idea of not talking to the police is
10 levels below No in fact you must
because the cops will come to you if
you're a governor in uh Chihuahua yeah
you and and I'm the boss you come to me
and say look I'm having a problem with
these gangbangers they're they're
dropping bodies all this kind of
foolishness plus I need to bring too
much attention exactly plus I need some
roads paved plus I need I need a new
water supply you know for the town what
can you do for me and and then that's
how I say I'll take care of all of it
but now my drugs need to move through
your state unfettered in fact we need
the military to protect it and that's
how drug routes are established okay
okay is is are the cartels my nipples
are hard
are the cartels in Mexico almost similar
to like um like big Tech in America and
where like the business has just grown
so big and it's so important to the to
the government that it has to bind
together yeah you know what I'm saying
probably like for example like Facebook
it's like you work with the government
you have to yeah you're not an
independent company like if if a
politician wants something they make a
phone call right right yeah and I
imagine Mexico that is these
conglomerates are so massive and they're
so dependent both are dominated that
they kind of work together oh absolutely
they're completely interdependent
completely I mean that [__] they just
arrested uh a guy who used to work for
the former Administration uh the last
Mexico president okay the guy the
secretary of defense was taking hundreds
of millions of dollars in bribes from
Chapo that would be like Hillary Clinton
when she was working for Obama yeah you
know dealing with you know whoever the
biggest criminal in the country so if
you're someone like Chapo that's like
maybe underneath one of these other guys
how do you not get clipped like how do
you keep yourself from getting fed yeah
oh yeah man and how do you use people
low profile you keep a low profile
because as soon as as soon as you like
El mencho you've heard of that guy I
don't know he's the guy that uh the the
competition to Sinaloa is the Nuevo
Jalisco cartel yeah and they're the guys
out of Jalisco yeah and Men show is
their leader and he's getting he's
getting hot he's getting way too hot now
they're coming for him if he's not
already dead they're like actively
looking and by they you mean the
government and the other cartels or just
the other cartels just the government
the Mexican Government because they need
support from America and America is like
look we're going to give you all this
these stimulus for your economy and for
your military but we need some headlines
so why did Joe Biden Joe Biden
was in Mexico last month what happened
three days before he visited they came
in snatched a video out of culiacan wow
wait wait wait so break down this
relationship we need support from the
United States for other things non-drug
relationship uh we're geopolitical
partners and we need to have like um
what is it like certain political wins
in order to Curry favor yeah it's all
about appearances so we need to look
like we got this drug [__] under control
of course oh [__] yeah so if you're not
Top Dog
you're fine you you're either fine or
you're getting clipped if you get too
hot that's the thing like yeah it's
almost like hmm if yeah there's like a
nice comfortable like Middle Ground yeah
absolutely absolutely you don't even
want to go higher than that and a guy
told us just that the guide who's who's
taking us around kulia Khan was like
nobody wants to be Chapo anymore anymore
you gotta blast through that dangerous
no you need to be doing that no but you
need the escape Velocity he's right
because if you get to the point where
you're interfacing with the government
right you're keeping [__] cool and
you're the one feeding yeah the new
folks you're straight yeah but breaking
through that yeah it's it's terrifying
and in my my opinion there's no more
doing that well there's no more because
the old days are gone everything's
decentralized there's radar everywhere
they can the satellite can you know pick
up your license plate from space it's
just everything is too so in other words
there's there's the technology to arrest
whoever we want exactly in a moment's
notice so if anybody is pushing weight
it has been allowed yes and you cannot
not become like one of these like
grandfather kingpins anymore like you're
just gonna get you're just gonna get
caught you're gonna get popped without
the grandfather kingpins is Mexico any
safer and like the way we look at it the
cartel runs everything it's dangerous
does that a lot of that go away with
with people not trying to be Top Dog I
feel like it's worse no probably worse
yeah because everybody's you know when
there's no structure up top all the
[__] all the rats are trying to grab
that cheese you know yeah so it's going
off right yeah yeah now the scene alone
is getting weakened because they came
and arrested ovidio yes you got now
you're gonna have warring parties go in
there so it's almost better that all the
illegal activity is done by one group a
couple of them yeah a couple that's kind
of how it works up in Canada where like
uh like the cambodians will handle the
illegal gambling and the Italians will
do this and then the Chinese will do
that as it's monopolized you can bargain
yeah and they and everybody kind of
knows each other's space yeah and
they're [__] Canadian about it yeah
they're not like too disrespectful
[__] annoying though but it stays
safer yeah when everybody's beefing and
going after it and thinks that they're
gonna be Top Dog of course that's where
you get people starting to get murdered
of course but you can't be top dog in
Canada you can't be top dog in America
there's no real kingpins because you're
always getting it from somebody in
Mexico
you control the manufacturing dude like
you it gets no higher than that so
that's that those are the only that's
what being a Kingpin really is you have
to own the supply you have to own the
distribution they control how much
product gets shipped up when you
literally control the price that is a
cartel that's OPEC that's oil yeah like
Federal Reserve you can make the prices
of [__] going in and out but now now
hang on to your britches now what's
happening is even that is getting flat
why because every because as the world
gets decentralized the cartels are no
longer monopolizing every level of the
drug chain so it used to be where if the
Sinaloa cartel had pretty much everybody
on payroll I pay the drivers I pay the
mules I pay the workers I have people in
the United States receiving the drugs to
to distribute it and sell send the money
back right it's not really like that
anymore it's all independent contractors
you're a trucker from culiacan I got a
load of fentanyl that needs to make it
to the border and I have the drug route
I will pay you for your services
rendered then and this is according to
Luis Luis chaparro a good friend who
works for Vice news is the number one
cartel journalist in all of Latin
America so this is not me talking this
is from him it's years of study and
being down there embedded uh you're a
truck driver you will move it to the
Border
then an American will meet you pay for
the drugs wholesale and they will mule
it across the board and then all these
people are completely separate exactly
and that's and it makes it impossible to
take an organization down that way so so
it is the fact that it's decentralized
creates more security for the people in
charge but there's less control over
what happens with the drugs of course
and that's where you get fentanyl
getting inserted into the coat totally
that's where you get other people
snitching so the risk is the snitching
you just hope that you could create
enough of a barrier between you and them
exactly yeah now now how [__] furious
were the cartels when the fentanyl stuff
was happening with the coke oh yeah well
I asked about that a ton down what they
say right they don't give a [__] I mean
they kind of give a [__] but like I was
like do you guys feel bad at all and
they were like oh no no no no no no no
no I'm not concerned about feeling bad
I'm more concerned about about the
product yeah so we went to burning man
right yeah and like oh you guys were
[__] we were treating your noses well
no no like I mean I did Coke once out
there I that was the only time I've ever
done Coke I'm not a big
uh it was it was awesome yeah it should
be this popular
like you've heard is good and you're
like oh he deserves it
does exactly what I wanted to do but
what
what I noticed from everyone buddy was
that the Casual drug went from I mean
I'm going to Burning Man a bunch of
times it was coke only to ketamine yeah
and there the overwhelming reaction to
Coke initially was like oh yeah I don't
trust the Coker all right we gotta test
the coke now if I'm a cartel boss that
makes money off of Coke I'm going we
have a marketing issue right here yeah
yeah actually
I take it back you're right because what
they've started to do is when they send
the fentanyl pills up to the Border they
are starting to make them pink
so so you can't crush it into the things
and when you do when you do you'll see
that when you're sniffing Coke on the
U.S side and it looks a little pink stay
away from it because that means a
dumbass dealer has crushed up Fentanyl
and mixed it in with his with his powder
now you're helping people come on do
what I can man you know [__] because
that fentanyl [__] is game over right
game over game over I had friends die
from it yeah really my favorite Barber
died of it that's why I'm rocking this
mullet I don't know what to do it's like
losing a [__] loved one bro seven
years this [__] you know no went and
kicked the bucket just one line because
he thought he was blowing Coke of course
yeah yeah we lost a couple Comics that
way exactly and not the not the comics
we wanted you know
yeah you know so how do you not get back
in the game because I I used to do it
very low like talking about it right now
oh my God
keep talking about Jail jail so I don't
even think about it I'm glad we got that
[__] out there well it's like alcoholic
goes to AAA meetings and talks about man
you remember when I used to black out
and you know wake up with a dick in my
mouth like he does that to remind
himself of the horrible exactly or or
just to get it out because they love
talking about alcoholic War Stories
that's that's kind of why I do this you
know because I do love talking about it
gives me my rush and then I can fall
back you know here's something safe
there's not to say